going to work making your way in the
army is pretty much the same as in
civilian life basically you have to know
your job you have to be willing to work
and you have to know how to get along
with people while the fundamental
requirements may be the same there are
some differences a little something
extra for example I want you to talking
about you both no student has a chance
for I'm glad everyone knows exactly who
should get my recommendation for that
assignment
because I don't I don't and
I'm their commanding officer it's not as
if one girl stood head and shoulders
above the other they're all fine girls
and they all deserve the assignment now
how can anybody make a sensible decision
in a situation like this let me see the
most deserve the assignment Susan
Marilyn Carol
I guess the co-workers know more about
them than anyone else well thank you mr.
Joe okay so you want to know about
Marilyn we have a fine group of girls in
this office they do a wonderful job I
suppose Marilyn has always been a
favorite of mine she does a wonderful
job and besides she's kind of nice to
have around a wonderful girl
okay she's the hard worker
we're all hard workers what does that
got to do with anything she's terrific
like a girl that hasn't heard it believe
me
I guess Marilyn is one of the prettiest
girls in my company
but I must say she doesn't always make
the most of it she forgets herself and
wears jewelry with her uniform the
extreme hairstyles she wears from time
to time don't exactly go well with her
whack uniform
she likes to hike up her skirt so that
it becomes a miniskirt she's a bright
girl but she's going to have to improve
we don't really fun on wearing jewelry
all dramatic hairstyle or the new
looking clothes
I think the miniskirt passed you
bell-bottoms are great in their place
and that's the key when what is
appropriate to time and place for
example this family is me where this
girl's genetic makeup extreme hairstyles
and her gown is beautiful but I'm sure
you would agree that sneakers are
ridiculous with this kind of costume
selecting the right makeup and the right
dress are more than matters of taste
with us in one important sense that what
we mean by military manners no one would
do a good job but her personal
appearance I still have a decision to
make here now let me see Terry Robertson
would also be good
she's an entirely different kind of girl
oh yes I'm gonna tell you later the test
results here we're all summarized at the
end of the report with the conclusions
of the colonel gaben that's real fine
spatulas traversing thank you so much
you're welcome
you can always depend on Carol she
really applies herself and works hard in
fact sometimes I think she knows more
about what's going on here than I do
she's a real marvel but that's not just
my opinion ask anyone they'll tell you
the same thing about special traversing
the most efficient person in this office
she works on their own projects and more
important she's always there to help
somebody if you look over there you can
see what I mean now let me get this
right two definitions if I decided on
her work alone I suppose I would
recommend Carol she does a superb job
but there's more to it than that and
Carol have to correct a few little
problems as she hopes to get anywhere
Carol is neat clean
and could be attractive but I think
she's confused about a few things she
confuses military bearing and behavior
with male mannerisms well they're not
the same thing at all and her walk that
really is a problem she's forgotten that
the 30 inch step is for the drill field
and that every place else you walk like
a girl if she would only learn to walk
properly
I don't misunderstand me for a woman I
have nothing against Carol she's a fine
girl and I'm very pleased with her work
however every time I see her she carries
herself as if she were on a parade field
I feel that our young ladies around here
can walk and talk
stand and sit like young ladies and I
see no reason for them to change just
because they're in uniform yeah great
thank you for coming back
what I need a real problem
now Susan Mayfield is something else
again she's not as efficient as Carol
but she is completely feminine at all
times and let me assure you that adds to
her military effectiveness she has all
the great and charm a young girl should
have she knows how to walk stand and sit
in a graceful feminine manner could you
come in and help me find certainly men
she also knows and practices all the
rules of military courtesy that she has
learned good morning ma'am
specialist Mayfield Jeb that new DEA
password on the first one of course yes
ma'am I filed it just this morning I'll
go and get it for you thank you holding
doors open standing while talking with
an officer are just a few examples of
proper military courtesy we service find
the respect which an enlisted person
chose her superior they also serve to
show the alertness and the awareness of
the individual those who tend to ignore
proper military courtesy will also
ignore courtesy in their civilian
behavior see you all there Thank You
specialist thank you excuse me ma'am I
believe my phone is ringing surely one
of the most serious problems in proper
military etiquette arises in answering
the telephone Susan knows how important
this is and she knows how it could be
done battalion headquarters specialist
Mayfield sir no I'm sorry sir captain
Foster isn't in right now well she is
expected back 11:30 would you like to
leave a message sir well here I thought
see that she gets it nature Murphy
call they would like to know status of
the theater report by 1300 hours this
afternoon will there be anything else
sir yes I'll see that she gets it
military manner yes but more than that
correct telephone technique is an
indication of personal effectiveness of
knowing how to get the job done the
composition yes I suppose
self-expression is one of the big
problems for many of our girls and this
goes beyond telephone answering alone in
many respects this is as important as
their appearance the trouble here is
people just don't know what they sound
like
but their goal very nose there's all the
difference in the world between that's
gonna take all day and I'll get it done
as quickly as possible sir
if people could hear themselves they
would realize how important the right
tone of voice the right selection of
words are well there you are
these are just a few of the things I
have to consider before making my
recommendation on which women will go to
Belgium many of the women put in a lot
of effort and never seem to get anywhere
I think just in what is acceptable and
what isn't may be helpful
for example we all know that you
shouldn't wear a miniskirt as part of
the uniform there's no question about
that and that you should walk in a
feminine manner at all times but we're
talking about apply there's much to
civilian life at the does to the
military the keyword in both studying
for fitness and would take now then who
do I recommend for the assignment to
Belgium
as a rule it goes to the girl who does
something about her career the girl who
didn't matter a little thought a little
effort in the final analysis girls it's
up to you